let's go next to just because we were
going to try
a foreign call let's go to
piet from germany piet from germany
you're on the air
hi dave can you hear me yes i can
my name is actually pronounced pete but
peter it's it's dutch
although i'm from germany that's allowed
no problem
okay so my
is in germany on the far right we have
kind of the same problem as in the u.s
where if
those normal right wingers who
care about the deficit or something like
that yeah
and with those cured on people who are
absolutely nuts who right think donald
trump is
the new jesus and such stuff and
my question is how how can we fix it how
can we
get rid of those curano people because
they are as you can see with the with
the capital
until it
and they they can do a lot of harm to
you know every country they're in oh my
god
this is a crazy connection pete are you
blowing into the phone while slamming it
into a counter right now
no you're not okay listen here's the
deal
it it is a long-term thing to fix that
the q the fact that the the republicans
were primed to fall for like the trump
and trumpy and q and
stuff doesn't happen overnight it's been
like a 40-year
programming in the united states so it
will take a long time to do away with it
and it comes down to education
epistemology
cultural change it's a big it's probably
a multi-decade project
so i i was wondering that because
i know you have done also videos about
how
this happened but we have the same
problem here with
you know there is no republican party
it's a party where
yeah all the kewano people are
popped up popped up like eight years ago
or something
but you have q anon in germany you're
saying
yes and that is my question how can
we get rid of anon i mean are they
american q anon people
who are in germany i mean they're
german but they believed the same stuff
as
the american people they they also
think bill gates is is drinking the
blood of people and
it's a great safe yeah such stuff listen
i don't know how to fix it i don't know
how to fix it here and and i don't know
how to fix it there but it's disturbing
that you're also dealing with it pete
yes obviously all right pete thank you
it's an unusual connection but i was
able to um
ultimately understand the question and i
appreciate you
um calling in for sure
let's go next to
where do we want to go how about trey
from missouri
trey you're on the air can you hear me
yes i can
so i tried calling it last week and it
just didn't work so i'm glad that i was
able to get on the air this time
i'm glad too um so obviously a big fan
of the show i had a question about
purity tests
and sort of litmus tests i was watching
one of uh the politicon panels with
you and anna casparian and kyle and
bukhari and
milo and one of the things that i got
out of it was the only real litmus test
to a
presidential to a candidate in any
elected office is whether they take
corporate pac money with sort of anna
casparian sort of kind of idea
do you think that that is good for all
political candidates regardless of party
and in particular on the left do you
think that that would be a winning
strategy
is if we tell democrats and democratic
leading candidates stop taking corporate
pac money
no i i listen i i don't that was a
couple years ago and did you say
milo was on the panel i don't remember
that
no maybe not my someone someone else was
on the panel i just remember who it was
oh okay um no listen i mean the the not
taking corporate pac money
is a great thing and i'm i love seeing
more candidates doing that
i don't think that that is like the
deciding line as to whether someone is
or isn't a good candidate and there's
there's
districts where that probably wouldn't
even make a difference so no i
i mean listen in politics there's very
few like hard and fast rules
and i i want to get corporate pac money
out
uh we should we need campaign finance
reform but no it's not like the be-all
end-all but it's a great thing i i think
in some places it won't make a big
difference
all right i just had a question about
that i i just i know that there are some
people on the progressive left who want
that to be the end all be
all standard well i don't i don't know
who want who says that that's the be-all
end-all
standard uh tray but it's certainly
something to aspire to i just don't
think at this point it's it's yet like a
difference maker or needs to be
necessarily a litmus test in all
districts
all right thank you david no problem uh
there is trey from missouri with
things not muted in the background but
we're tolerating all of it of course